مرحبًا بكم في نادي رويال غرينز للجولف والنادي الريفي
المحاط بأكثر من الرمال والبحر
، اكتسب هذا المكان سمعة باعتباره
أحد أفضل الأماكن في الشرق الأوسط ،
فما الذي يتطلبه الأمر بالضبط لبناء
ملعب جولف من عيار البطولات في الصحراء من
نقطة الصفر.
في سبتمبر 2017
، استضافت رويال غرينز بالفعل بعضًا من أفضل الألعاب في العالم
مع بطل الأساتذة المتوج حديثًا ،
داستن جونسون ، الذي أعلن فوزه
في النسخة الأولى من بطولة السعودية الدولية في عام
2019 ، تم
عرض مياه البحر الأحمر الصافية
بالكامل في
الحفرة رقم 16 المميزة في الملعب
مع مناظر خلابة.  من t إلى اللون الأخضر
ولكن كما أوضح المهندس المعماري المسؤول عن
الدورة التدريبية ،
فقد اتخذ التصميم تقريبًا اتجاهًا مختلفًا تمامًا
في الخطط الأولية ، كان اللون الأخضر السادس عشر
يقع في الواقع على بعد
حوالي 50 60 مترًا من
الساحل وقلنا لهم فقط انظروا أنك
تريد  سوق ملعب الجولف هذا ،
احصل على هذا اللون الأخضر على حافة البحر الأحمر
وهو ما هو عليه اليوم
كما هو الحال في الوقت الحالي  بعض الاختبارات الفريدة
لمصمم المناظر الطبيعية الصحراوية تقدم أيضًا
الكثير من التحديات لديفيد
بلير الرجل المكلف بصيانة
هذه الدورة ذات المستوى العالمي ،
إنها بيئة قاسية لدينا
درجات حرارة عالية لدينا رطوبة
عالية رياح عاتية في فترة بعد الظهر قليلة
هطول الأمطار
الآن  نحن نتعامل مع الكثير من التصحيحات الجافة في
ملعب
الجولف ، والتحدي موجود
لإعادة هذه الظروف إلى
المستوى الذي نحتاجه ،
فلديك بعض اللاعبين
المشهورين هنا بالتأكيد في السعودية
الدولية والآن لدينا بعض اللاعبين في العالم  أفضل
السيدات هنا ،
ما هي التعليقات التي قدمها
الجميع مجانًا عن ملعب الجولف
، ومن أول حدث
للرجال إلى حدث الرجال الثاني ،
تتحسن التعليقات في كل مرة تتحسن فيها
الظروف
، ونحن نسعى جاهدين لتحقيق الأفضل كل عام